check this out here's a grid nothing
special just a basic grid very gritty
but look closer into this white spot at
the center where the two central
vertical and horizontal lines intersect
look very closely notice anything funny
about this spot yeah nothing but keep
looking get weird and stare at it now
keeping your gaze fixed on this white
spot check what's happening in your
peripheral vision the other spots are
they still white or do they show weird
flashes of grey
now look at this pan for baking muffins
oh sorry
one of the cups is inverted it pops up
instead of dipping down wait no spin the
pan the other five are domed now
whichever it is this pans defective
here's a photo of Abraham Lincoln and
here's one upside down nothing weird
going on here wait turn that upside down
one right side up what have they done to
Abe
those are just three optical illusions
images that seem to trick us how do they
work our magical things happening in the
images themselves while we could
certainly be sneaking flashes of gray
into the peripheral white spots of our
animated grid first off we promise we
aren't you'll see the same effect with a
grid printed on a plain old piece of
paper in reality this grid really is
just a grid but not to your brains
visual system here's how it interprets
the light information you call this grid
the white intersections are surrounded
by relatively more white on all four
sides than any white point along a line
segment your retinal ganglion cells
notice that there is more white around
the intersections because they are
organized to increase contrast with
lateral inhibition better contrast means
it's easier to see the edge of something
and things are what your eyes and brain
have evolved to see your retinal
ganglion cells don't respond as much at
the crossings because there is more
lateral inhibition from more white spots
nearby compared to the lines which are
surrounded by black this isn't just a
defect in your eyes if you can see then
optical illusions can trick you with
your glasses on or with this paper or
computer screen right up in your face
what optical illusions show us is the
way your photoreceptors and brain
assemble visual information into the
three-dimensional world you see around
you where edges should get extra
attention because things with edges can
help you or kill you
look at that muffin pan again you know
what causes confusion here your brains
visual cortex operates on assumptions
about the lighting of this image it
expects light to come from a single
source shining down from above and so
these shading patterns could only have
been caused by light shining down on the
sloping sides of a dome or the bottom of
a hole if we carefully recreate these
Clues by drawing shading patterns even
on a flat piece of paper our brain
reflexively creates the 3d concave or
convex shape now for that creepy Lincoln
upside down face
faces trigger activity in areas of the
brain that have specifically evolved to
help us recognize faces like the
fusiform face area and others in the
occipital and temporal lobes it makes
sense to we're very social animals with
highly complex ways of interacting with
each other when we see faces we have to
recognize they are faces and figure out
what they're expressing very quickly and
what we focus on most are the eyes and
mouth that's how we figure out if
someone is mad at us or wants to be our
friend in the upside down Lincoln face
the eyes and mouth were actually
right-side up so you didn't notice
anything was off but when we flipped the
whole image over the most important
parts of the face the eyes and mouth
were now upside down and you realized
something fishy was up you realized your
brain had taken a shortcut and missed
something but your brain wasn't really
being lazy it's just very busy so it
spends cognitive energy as efficiently
as possible using assumptions about
visual information to create a tailored
edited vision of the world imagine your
brain calling out these edits on the fly
ok those squares could be objects let's
enhance that black/white contrast on the
sides with lateral inhibition darken
those corners dark gray fading into
light gray assume overhead sunlight
falling on a sloping curve next those
eyes look like most eyes I've seen
before nothing weird going on here
see our visual tricks have revealed your
brains job as a busy director of 3d
animation in a studio inside your skull
allocating cognitive energy and
constructing a world on the fly with
tried and mostly but not always true
tricks of its own
you